well first of all mr walker thank you so
much for coming in and helping us
celebrate the life of paul
thank you i appreciate that how are you
doing it's it's a sad time uh we're very
close loving family and paul
there's a
piece that's missing now that
we're always gonna miss
right after paul's death
you actually said i'm just glad that
every time i saw him i told him i loved
him and he said the same thing to me his
heart was so big i was so proud of him
every
day of his life
what a wonderful thing for a father to
be able to say
it was very easy for me to say though
because it was so true
the last time i saw him he was sitting
on the couch
but doing this always mr jiggly foot
and i said you know we ought to start
calling you saint paul all the nice
things you do and he goes oh
he goes
you know i appreciate that we always
gave each other a hug he'd give me a
kiss on the cheek i'd give him one tell
him i loved him it's a great memory i
was just gonna say what a great winning
race good feeling i thank god i see
thank you for giving me this great kid
this wonderful man this person that
lit up a lot of people's lives you know
he didn't like hollywood
he didn't like it
he didn't like it did he feel like he
didn't fit in
it was important to paul that he be real
though what you saw on film yes was paul
yeah and that was paul sat him down one
time and i says paul
do you realize what lies what a
miserable place planet earth would be
without entertainers
without singers without writers without
actors i says they bring sunshine into
our lives
maybe a little gloomy if some you know a
real dramatic but i said what a sad
place the world would be be proud of
what you do
you make people feel good
yeah and he said you know i didn't think
of it that way how ironic that the last
few hours of his life he was doing good
for other people
he was doing exactly what you're talking
about take me back to that day take me
back to the moment where you found out
that he had been in an accident and had
passed i was on my motorcycle i kept
getting calls and i call and my brother
says
paul
has been killed
i'm thinking somebody's got it wrong
where are you at when did it happen he
says you need to get over to the house
everybody's there
i said okay this is i'm about 45 minutes
away
and
i pulled my phone up
and i
my feet wouldn't move there was this
young guy next to me he just pulled up
and i said buddy would you do me a favor
and put air in my rear tire
i i can't do it
he said sure dude
i said
i just turned my son was killed
and he looked at me and he just reached
up and gave me a big hug he said i'm so
sorry
i don't know if he's out there or maybe
he'll watch this program and he'll know
this old guy was on that motorcycle
but
i'd like to say thank you to him
have you been able to go back to the
crash site have you been there quite a
few times you have what is that like
i like to read little notes of people
leave you ought to see the beautiful
sentiments people leave there what kind
of dad was paul
he just he was a cuddler
and he would say to meadow come on talk
to your grandfather you know because
you're shy she's a shy gal
and you see all their pictures are like
this every picture i've seen them
there's just
they're cuddling
they are so
you just see the love in their faces i
guess is what i want to say it's very
true the fast and furious cast have you
spoken with them have you kept
paul loved tyrese
he loved ludacris
michelle rodriguez he said was the most
fun person to go out on the town with
dude almost had you
you almost had me
paul loved him
paul said i'm east coast he's west coast
he says venn is perfectionist
paul says i want to say let's just get
it done so we can go goofy
he did the stare and drive on you didn't
he got that from me
tyreese oh he'd said a prayer at the
house that was just tore my heart out
what did he say yeah just all hold hands
thank you for knowing paul
having the privilege of knowing him
and the light that he brought into our
lives
and the goodness that he did
in the hopes that we would pass that
legacy onward and ever be ever mindful
of
goodness in the world no i know um caleb
and cody were able to step in oh gosh
it'll be the body doubles for paul and
fast and furious seven
hey because you could leave without
saying goodbye
i went on set one time it was very hard
because they looked just like paul was
it tough for them to be able to do that
because they are trying to be there
people were wonderful to them they were
they said it was incredible it was an
incredible experience everybody
they said dad these people really love
paul and i said yeah now they love you
you're the his brother oh you get around
you you're the same they're the same as
paul yeah
they're all chipped from the same brick
so they felt honored to be able to
finish
yes the movie they're just a big-hearted
men what's the one thing that you think
people
don't know about paul
that they should know
what you saw what you got
paul
boy his love of people was so genuine
his soul was huge
he didn't want to talk about himself he
wanted you to tell him what you did
that was
important to him i want to see the
pictures you brought
you got a lot of pictures throughout the
years there oh yeah
that's him
that's him a little guy he still got the
same smile he had what is he even how
old is he there not even a year no
we always said he was very well fed
wasn't he
look at what he turned out to be that's
pretty good now this is a christmas
picture of the whole family
see how much they look like mom oh well
you all have blue eye all of them and
here's paul this is probably in powers
oregon we had we like to go up there
paul and water and fishing oh as soon as
we'd stop well him and his brother too
caleb too where'd they go they got their
fishing poles they're done with the
river they were off doing something fun
yep
they would and
look they were boys like he was like a
tom sawyer
you know just huckleberry finn
what do you want people to remember
about him the most
he was the real deal he's the fine man
and
he's
the kind of man you want to be like
if you want to
liken yourself or
follow the foot systems steps of
somebody it should be paul william
walker the fourth because he was as fine
a person as there ever was
and he would have gotten better
[Music]
you